[Music]
I went to college at Ole Miss the
University of Mississippi and I got a
telephone call from the Chancellor one
day and he says Harold we have got to
get the flags the Confederate flags off
the campus and I said Robert I think
you're smoking pot and he said no I'm
not kidding you he said what was bad to
do it and I said why have we got to do
it and he said you know I've been here
for one year
I expect to be here for nine more and I
want my legacy to be that I made this a
great public university and he said as
long as those flags on us on the campus
nothing never happened it was nothing
I'd be thought regarded that way and so
I reluctantly said I'll come down and
spend a couple of days with you and
we'll talk about it I'll talk to one of
your people to see how they feel about
this and feeling that I got on the
campus he was that I'm all for getting
the flags off the campus but I am NOT
going to be in the front row cheering
that we have to do it and that came from
all different levels and my last
interview was with the coach of the
football team and I said coach all the
flags affecting your football program he
said they're killing us and I said will
he go a little slower and tell me how
that works
and he said
stay in Mississippi the best football
players a black and with the flags on
campus we are not getting our share of
the black players they're going to other
schools and Ole Miss was one of the few
schools that still kept the flags on the
state on the campus and I said coach I
said coach you're the only person who
can get the flags off the state of the
campus and he said why do you say that
and I said your redneck supporters since
you described them will take your head
off if you go in that direction I said
that much rather have a winning football
team than have the flags on a statement
on our campus it was a trade off I had a
lot of leverage and he said well you may
be right but he said I'm I'm not going
to get involved in politics or this
thing right now and I said want you to
have a press conference and say if you
want a winning football team you're
going to have to take the flags off the
statements off the ground of campus
grounds so that we can put together a
winning football team and after two ends
there were no more fights in a statement
haven't been since 1997 and so the
problem is in most situations you don't
have that clean a trade off I can't give
you exactly what you want or as much of
what you want and
that is really I think the key to
changing people's minds about various
issues
[Music]